so good afternoon everyone and welcome
back to elizabeth house for this council
meeting on the 18th of october 2021.
a reminder of some housekeeping please
have your mobile phones switched off or
on silent
and a reminder that the meeting is also
being broadcast live and members of the
public are able to view
the proceedings uh please welcome
reverend jim edy to say praise
thank you councillorfitter
i'm actually something for you to
reflect
on this afternoon as you go about your
council business i want to describe
a cartoon to you that was circulating
during lockdown
it is of a father and a son standing
looking over a wall surveying all before
them
and they look upon a scene of
destruction
a wasteland in the foreground
and in the distance uh city or town
is burning
there is an upturned car
ablaze also
and the father has turned to the sun and
is saying
one day son
all this will be yours
whilst at their feet
two rats are fleeing for their lives
with the shocking events of recent days
chaos at the pumps in the recent weeks
or as we look out across our world at
the inequality
and environmental situation
i wonder if this scene chimes with you
many of us will be hoping that cop 26
will lead our world into a safer and
more sustainable
sustainable
place environmentally
but we also know that the right people
need to be around
the table
and unfortunately experience so far
hasn't shown this is likely to be the
case
something to pray about
or maybe it is friday's events that fit
into the theme of the cartoon
as you consider what you
will be passing on
the awful killing of sir david amos in a
methodist church in lee on sea
presents yet another attack
on the way our democracy operates
for any of us holding public office
this along of course with the murder of
joe cox in 2016
sends a shockwave through us
as we reflect on how we operate and what
we stand for
along with those close to david his
family and friends my prayers were and
still are
also with you
following
that attack
being out in the community face to face
with members of the public is what you
do
it is something i'm sure you're
passionate about
and recognize is central to your role
but something that feels a little more
threatened
than it did
david of course with some of the deep
christian faith and many commentators
have reflected on this in tributes that
have been written
the archbishop of york stephen cottrell
wrote such a tribute yesterday in the
telegraph i recommend reading it
if the telegraph isn't your paper of
choice
the tribute can be found in full on the
archbishop's website
he comments the comments that david amos
didn't wear his faith on his sleeve he
wore it in his heart
that's the best place for it
it means it runs through your very being
it's the christian faith and outlook
is what motivated
david and it's one that paints hope for
a few for the future
it's a hope that motivates us to
continue to stand for what we believe
despite the challenges
it is a hope that motivates us to strive
for safeguarding our planet and
environments
it is something that motivates us to
pray for who all who are involved
but sometimes
it's difficult to know how to speak to
god it's difficult to know how to pray
but jesus helped with this in some of
his most radical words
that form what we now call the lord's
prayer
these were radical in their day two
thousand years ago
and if we stop to reflect on them they
are as radical today
so if you're unsure how to pray about
what we're all experiencing
if you like me
find yourself as the dad the parents
the grandparents or guardian in the
cartoon
scared about what we are passing on
turn to jesus's prayer the lord's prayer
which is how i'm going to finish now
if you wish to join with me please do
either in silence
or aloud
our father who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come thy will be done
on earth as it is in heaven
give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our trespasses
as we forgive those who trespass against
us
and lead us not into temptation
but deliver us from evil
for thine is the kingdom the power and
the glory
forever and ever amen
thank you
thank you
uh the events on friday were shocking
and heartbreaking
so david amis was a dedicated public
servant and he lost his life doing the
job he loved serving his constituents a
role he performed with distinction for
nearly four decades and our thoughts are
with his wife children and family
please now join me in a minute silence
thank you
so item agenda one apologies for absence
i invite the head of paid service to
report the list of apologies
thank you chairman um we have eight
apologies this afternoon uh councillor
jill cleve councillor neil eddon
councillor jackie harris councillor
councilor tony jefferson councillor matt
jennings
excellent danny kendall and councillor
penny ann o'donnell thank you
thank you um item two disclosures of
interest
chairman if i could just say that in
regard to item eight
which is the boundary commission
proposals i'm granting a dispensation to
all councillors who all have common
interests in this just to ensure that
there's a proper democratic debate thank
you
thank you um i now invite members to
make any other declarations of interests
thank you uh the minutes for the meeting
held on 12th of july i now seek a
proposal please and the second
uh for the minutes
we've got a proposal
thank you councillor perry and the
second uh your counselor kettle
that's all agreed
so item four so um i'm really enjoying
uh my time as the chairman and i'm
pleased
i'm pleased to check my instagram
account see photographs of what i'm up
to last week we welcomed back the the
mop fair
and i'm pleased to report back that
myself and councillors olcock cleve
kessler and dixon are all unharmed after
i'll go on the dodge rooms despite
councillor kettle's best attempts
otherwise
on friday the 5th november
you may have seen but all councils are
invited to join me at the heart of
england forest in dorsington
uh where we'll have an introduction to
the charity the heartland forest
followed by some tree planting for about
an hour and all councils will be able to
do that and then we'll return to
volunteer hub for tea and coffee
and that week also marks the start of uh
tree planting season
and the charity will have their pr team
and many senior charity workers there as
well so thank you to those who are rsvp
so far we'll send out another reminder
so please do and try to come along and
be a good event
um
and earlier today i received a petition
on planning law changes
and the petition
was titled that we
undersigned are concerned at the
proposed government changes to the
planning laws
we believe planning works best when
developers and the local community work
together to shape local areas and
deliver necessary new homes and
therefore call on stratfor district
council
to one support and voice these concerns
publicly and two to call on the
government to protect the rights of
communities to object of in individual
planning applications
uh we've also got some awards uh today
so um these are for the staff long
service awards
and i'd like to congratulate the
following staff who have recently
achieved
long-term service awards so for 25 years
service
we've got eddie chizik
and wales
pat majesk gina lewis
sue steele rebecca hartnett and joe
manning for 25 years service and for
40-year service we've got phil franklin
so please join me in a quick round of
applause for those officers
thank you
i'll now invite councillor pembington as
deputy leader on behalf the leader to
make any announcements that he may have
thank you thank you very much chairman
and i'm just standing in at a relatively
short notice for the leader who is who
is unwell today uh and i wish him a a
speedy recovery and i imagine so do you
so you don't have to have me running
these meetings
um i've only really won announcements
and that really is in relation to robert
weeks
robert weeks some of you may know has
served 36 years with this authority
and
having served man and boy
retires on the 29th of october
robert has had
an illustrious career
his high point was starting
in birmingham which we all know is god's
own city at birmingham city council in
july of 1994.
he was however soon attracted by the
bright lights of stratford-upon-avon
where he joined this authority
stratford-unhaven district council in
may on the 3rd of may 1985 as a district
environmental health officer
his talents were soon recognized and by
no by 1988 he'd been promoted to
divisional environmental health officer
serving the ulster area officer
through then he moved on to become a
principal officer and ultimately
becoming head of environmental health in
november of 2001 following the
retirement of alan savory
a year later
he took on the responsibility for health
and housing
became head of environment in 2006
and in 2011 brought together environment
and planning
before becoming our first joint of head
of development in august of this year
um i've
known rob and worked with rob since i
was first elected to this authority in
in 2001
um and really nobody deserves that long
working with me hanius performs a
sterling
and
very professional job i have never had
an occasion where
rob has been lost for words uh despite
uh some of my more mad cap ideas and
schemes around planning applications in
bidford.even
he's always been a can-do and uh person
and a person who comes up with a
solution um he's always looking to
provide the best
he has always been a man who has
supported and fought for his team
and backed them to the hill and i think
that everybody who's worked with him as
an officer in this council would
recognize that strength and recognize
that the support that he's given
professionally and personally sometimes
to to officers um
and he sort of run through this
authority during that period and has
become part of our dna and becomes sort
of part of what's best of us of our
officers
and he will indeed be a hard act to
follow um
he's he's going to be spending more time
doing the real things in life some of
you will will know he has a number of
passions including playing his guitar
he's a
much like myself a sort of child of the
punk era a bit too late to be one of the
fab four and the clash wouldn't have him
um but i'm sure that he'll enjoy
his retirement he's running he's fishing
and cooking and i'm sure that he will uh
he will um he will pop in from time to
time and
let us know how we're we're not doing it
right the rob weeks way
so really i just want to pay a personal
thanks for all of the support that rob
has given me personally as a member
over my 20 years i know that pretty much
every member could do so
again and uh i'd like us just to have a
huge round of applause for rob for his
service and wishing in his retirement
thank you councillor my invite as
councillor junior please
are we
allowed to
stand in this
i don't know the rules anymore
um i've i've actually known uh robert
week since i first became a councillor
in 1991 so uh even earlier and even
longer than
yourself council pemberton
and i've always found him someone who's
given very balanced and very wise views
to councillors of all political
persuasions no matter what uh we've
asked of him
can i particularly mention um the role
that he took on with the task and finish
group when we looked at the emergency um
the climate change emergency and we took
on that role as a task and finish
it was um under very
considerable time pressures um it was a
very difficult and a very expansive
subject to cover in a short time
but his advice and support was very much
appreciated during that time so i truly
wish him well
i certainly recognize the standard of
his work and i truly wish him well into
retirement and i do hope he keeps in
touch thank you to to robert weeks
thank you councillor parry
thank you chairman um just as the
portfolio holder for planning i would
just like to endorse councillor
pemberton's
um words and also councillor dunedin's
words um it's been a real pleasure to
have
um robert to serve with robert weeks
he has given me so much
support and endorsement um and help
since i've been a counselor
well since 2 2014
he is going to be really missed by all
the staff as well as ourselves
someone who's so personal um and a great
go-to person whenever you have a problem
he's certainly a hard act to follow um
thank you robert for everything you've
done and we will miss you thank you
thank you i now invite david buckland
the chief executive to make any
announcements
thank you chairman and good afternoon
council and isn't it good to be back
here after 20 months i just wanted to
firstly say thank you for everybody for
for taking the measure so seriously and
and taking the national protests today
that they really are important um
secondly i just want to join the
tributes to rob rob it's been an
extremely valued member of the
management team i joined the council
back in may 2002 so maybe not quite as
long as councillor junior and council
pemberton but rob has been a fantastic
aide in the management team and he will
be sorely missed so i indeed wish him
all the very best for his retirement
thank you chairman
thank you
moving on to item agenda 5 the
membership of the council former
councillor john appleton
i now refer to the death of former
councillor john appleton former district
councillor for the southern ward from
2004 to 2012.
councillor alberton also served
as a warwickshire county councillor for
the southern division from 2005 to 2017.
i invite councillor pemberton as deputy
leader to address the meeting followed
by council iraq
and council dixon
thank thank you chairman um councillors
um brock and dickson um
respectively uh worked uh through
cabinet and um as uh
adjoining ward members and
and
knew
john uh on that basis um
better than i did but i did uh serve
with john throughout his time on the
district council and particularly served
with him on planning committees um and
what i found uh with john um was someone
who was
quiet and reserved but within that um
very focused on what he said uh he
didn't
uh waste time and he for me got to the
point and that point was always good
that point was always valid that what
point was always intellectually thought
through
and
was also a member who
did things with
a good sense of humor and a
smile on his face
a member who to me struck me as somebody
who didn't take himself too seriously
but someone who actually took his role
and what he was doing for his residents
absolutely seriously
he was a hard-working and very effective
member of this council uh i don't know
that um his his he he will be sorely
missed by his his family and
and his friends and he will be missed by
residents who had the benefit of
him working for them um between 2004 and
2017 across both this and and the county
council so um i i will miss john i think
he was a very effective um counsellor
and he was a good guy
and i think that's
what we could all aspire to being
effective and being noted as a good guy
or gal for that matter um but i will i
will leave it at that uh with some
sadness and uh invite councillor rock
and then councillor dixon and of course
any other member who may wish to speak
thank you chair
uh thank you chairman thank you darren
um
regrettably this is the third time
in uh in recent months i've had to stand
up here
or elsewhere and mark the death of a
former colleague from this council
who lived in my world
and uh and someone i worked with
i enjoyed a good relationship with john
appleton
and although he represented southam in
the district he was my county councillor
and he held the division that andy crump
presently has
but he lived in prize master in my ward
and although he'd not been in the best
of health in recent times he continued
to be interested in district council
matters
bringing me up to ask difficult
questions which i had to go away and
find the answer
he could always ask the difficult
question
before the last general election i had a
long chat to him at his house this time
back wider if uh affair from the
district of course he was he was a
conservative
but uh we did find we had
a coalition of coalescence of views on
certain matters particularly europe
and this may not be coincidental because
we both
worked for ford of europe for quite a
period and we both saw the advantages of
european integration firsthand
also from our shared business experience
we both took an interest in quality
management about which we taught a great
deal when we were councillors because we
often shared lifts from the far east
to go to planning committees and come to
this council
and we we tried to work out how we could
apply those uh principles to the benefit
of the council
but it's both sad and ironic that after
one of my conversations with john
when he was clearly in failing health i
spoke to the late bob stevens about what
i perceived to be state of health
health
bob said i must look him up
and see how he's doing
little did we know that neither would
still would not be not be with us in a
matter of months
so i will miss them both
thank you very much
thank you chairman
john a hard act to follow yes
it's hard working
and i worked with john from when he was
joined the council through to 2010
period of six years
and we've already heard words spoken
about rob weeks
and obviously ice his portfolio at the
time worked very closely with rob and
and john as well
and certainly the the environment
housing affordable housing and a whole
gamut of interests uh that john was
interested in
he wasn't a councillor who would jump up
and down and make interesting little
points on every single issue but when
john spoke
as darren mentioned it was to his point
and focused
and was always of great value
he made you think but he was also
thinking outside the box as well
reference has been made um to health
and i must admit i was trying to recall
whether or not it was his own ill health
or family ill health
which precluded him from
serving in the best role
in this council
his name should have been on that board
he would have made an excellent chairman
and i can't think of any better praise
than the fact that he missed out on that
opportunity he should have had it he
would have been a
wonderful chairman
thank you thank you
thank you councillor crump
thank you chairman
like council iraq this is becoming
too much of a habit
losing too many good friends and
counselors who've had a great impact on
the community and hopefully this is the
last one for her for a good while
i know just catch the pemberton
mentioned he had a great sense of humor
but obviously i'm following her satan
tradition
and at his funeral um
yes that i just mentioned that cancer
promise is very funny so thank you for
that uh catch the riches um
um i will also found out he was an
aspiring musician
uh but in the skiffle group and did a
very mean impression of alvis presley so
something he didn't know about it but
john was sent
is that you catch the kettle
uh certainly very supportive of uh young
people
especially those in the early years
education and he was a great supporter
and great advocate for them
and it has been mentioned he became very
frowned in late in life
his mind was as sharp as a as a razer
with a strong steady determination
he was certainly on the phone to me
several times uh advocating uh what i
should be doing next um
and when i visited him he was like a
hoarder
he'd got papers going back
since he first became a counsellor you
know um
and that he got a great memory he knew
where those papers were so he could
actually go down
a great big pile of paper and it was
three quarters of the way there and he'd
almost find it straight away so
um
it's a sad loss
a strong determinant character who who
loved his community and was loved by his
community
but when he was raised he was like a
tiger so you didn't want to get on the
wrong side of john which hopefully i
didn't too often so some great tributes
here today so thank you very much on on
behalf of the safe and residents for
these wonderful tributes
and uh
god bless to john and all this family
thank you
thank you so um i will now move that the
council notes with regret the death
of former councillor john appleton and
extends its sympathy to his family and
friends and their loss
uh item six public participation um i
believe we haven't received any
questions
okay item seven state of the district i
invite councillor pemberton as deputy
leader of the council to introduce this
report on behalf of the leader
thank you chairman
each year um
we assess the state of the district and
produce a statement summarizing the
events of the past year
to give
also an outline of future proposals
and it provides uh background
information on the current climate
economically socially
and environmentally across the district
um
i would uh
draw your attention to just uh two items
uh in the report you you've all seen the
report and i undoubtedly had the
opportunity to read it
section one covered 19 the pandemic and
brexit
two
momentous
events
and the two events particularly the
pandemic that have shaped
the most recent period
and will continue to shape the next
period for for this authority and
members i would urge you to to consider
everything that said in the district uh
state of the district report uh in that
context
and
equally i would then also refer you to
page
51
objective 4 responded to the climate
emergency
that will continue to be
the single most important
issue that this authority
this nation and this planet addresses
it will continue to run through
everything that we do
we will make progress um are we
as a species making enough process no
we're not are we doing it quickly enough
no we're not
but what there is in this building and
shared in other buildings up and down
the land and across the world is a
determination that we are going to make
change here
so that will continue to be the back
gang context to future state of the
district reports
members
i ask you uh
to note the state of the district report
the issues that are raised within that
report
and
that those issues
will form and be considered as part of
the making process for 2223 and we'll of
course inform other decision-making
processes around as they set the context
um
i will leave it at that for you at this
moment members i think councillor junior
would wish to
yes um
i'm speaking particularly not only as um
leader of the liberal democrat group but
um as
a ward member for ulster in in what i'm
saying going to draw attention to
it's noted that um
in on housing that the median house
prices in the district are well above
england and warwickshire median and that
only 13 of houses are now socially
rented in the district and it's also
noted that affordable housing
completions although they've risen this
year's this year there is no definition
of whether these houses are social
housing or affordable houses to rent or
whether provision is in different towns
and villages meets the need in that
particular locality rather than being
provided where the developers choose to
put housing
and we know that waiting lists from
government figures we know that waiting
lists or affordable housing could double
next year because of the current cost of
living crisis which is driving up rent
areas and evictions and there's an
impending crisis with building staff and
building supply shortages as well as
income right earnings to house price
ratios
there's also noted in the in the report
that there's 2
382 dwellings vacant across the district
of of which over a thousand of low
clusters long-term vacant including 232
housing association properties
and it's also noted that there's a huge
variation in fuel poverty across the
district and that those numbers are
rising
i would like you to take on board i'd
like the leader to take on board those
particular parts of this review uh and
look at the problems that need to be
addressed
there are other questions that i'm sure
will be noted by my group
but i'd also particularly like to refer
to 11.2 and 11.3
and that refers to i'd like to
particularly report
refer there to the recent report on
government covey preparedness for the
pandemic
i have to say that um the the report was
produced by a a committee from the house
of commons that was cross party
committee at the house of commons
and some of the judgments that they've
reached were truly shocking
but what i would like to do is to
compare that to local government and the
response taken there
and to the staff of this council
and to gps and to nhs staff and to
communities because i think that sets it
a stark reminder of how important local
government is and local communities are
and that it was government and the
national trying to do everything too
much at a national stage which was a
problem and i'd like the council to
reflect on that and maybe see what else
the local government can do to reflect
to re respond and strengthen whatever it
can do in local government health and
support for this communities thank you
thank you council for chick
thank you chair um i just wanted to echo
what um councillor junior
said when she was
talking about housing
good housing is key to residents to live
healthier happier and safer lives
and we know in this district we have
the highest house prices in in the distr
in warwickshire
and it's gone up 30 in the last six
years
and i do acknowledge that more
affordable housing
has has been built um however i don't
see any figures on social housing
and for many residents living in this
district
i afford affordable housing
um
is still not affordable in the context
of very high house prices
so i'd like to see more figures that
separates those two things out
and
uh yeah that's about it really thank you
thank you then we then have council
jenny for actually counsellor marge rock
and counselor manuela patskiller so
counselor project
uh thank you chair i just wanted to make
a comment about the um kovid pandemic i
mean recently i've had emails and in
fact face to face uh on a street surgery
that was held on saturday
of parents coming to
express their extreme concerns about the
rise of infections within the school
setting
and the way in which those infections
now are actually seeping in into their
families
and
i'm not sure what this district can
actually do about it but i think it
should be raised
i've just come back from pet a short
stay in pasto
patsto
you could not go into a shop you could
not go into a pub without wearing a mask
and in fact we were in a pub one evening
when someone was refused entry because
they weren't wearing a mask
everywhere where people congregated
there were sanitizers attached to the
walls or to the benches i spoke to a
couple of shopkeepers
who said really as a town they came
together to make sure that they were
taking
proper control
of the situation as far as they were
concerned
and
they knew they were having visitors from
across the country coming to stay with
them in vast numbers
and they wanted to do their best to
control
the virus so jeff i wanted to raise
those two points one the fact that there
is concern among residents about the
rise in school and the impact that's
having and also
what we could do perhaps as small towns
across the district to actually improve
the wearing of masks and sanitizing
thank you well thank you uh
counselor rock
thank you chairman um well
just on the points about covid
uh he'll be surprised to hear me say
that but what i would just mention is
that the briefings that we had during
those first days of the covid and i
happened to be in a group with council
of pemberton and i have to say they were
very very good
and i very much appreciate how we the
information was shared and it was
it was a good exemplar of how we we
don't always agree about everything uh
and i hope i know i'm about to show that
in a second but uh certainly uh that
that sort of approach and i think uh
what council francis just said is let's
learn from what other people are doing
and we are
we are in a difficult position with
covid as we stand at the moment
um
however
when i look at page 51
i'm
astonished to find that we're having
monthly meetings with open reach
now open reach and dealing with open
reach and the implementation of
broadband and any communication with
open reach
i have found to be virtually impossible
to find that members of this council
have got monthly meetings with open
reach
has come as a surprise to me
so i would very much welcome and uh of
course the leader isn't here but i'm
sure darren will have to completely have
his finger on the pulse
perhaps you can tell us how that's going
where we get the feedback and if there's
a communication channel with open reach
about implementating implementing
broadband in rural areas which is a
nightmare for me i would appreciate it
thank you very much
thank you councillor bertogallo
yeah thank you um i'd like to draw
attention to um section 3.3 which is
population growth
and
that my word well for donavon has seen
the greatest population growth in the
past few years
and this is linked to um session
section 4.6 house building
uh for the past four years rural centers
and local service villages have seen the
majority on new house building following
the council dispersal policy
however this development and growth has
not been accompanied by um
infrastructure
so there's no ambitious
active travel infrastructure
the drainage infrastructure is regularly
failing uh we've seen broadband
infrastructure as well
it's an issue in our rural villages and
no social infrastructure i have
new residents that cannot register with
their with gps which is very concerning
um and so i just want to make the point
that this is no way to build sustainable
communities in our district
thank you councillor kettle
councillor kettle would you like to
speak
thank you mr chairman um
i think this report uh reflects the
enormous hard work that our officers in
this council have done
uh during a very very difficult
uh last 12 months
uh and i think we as a councillors
elected members should reflect on david
buckland and his team what they have
achieved during this incredibly
difficult time
um and the fact that we have managed to
prosper and move forward
um
a very little brief
um
statistic
uh if you go to page 41
30 percent of the businesses in
warwickshire
are in stratford in stratfor district
now we only represent
20 we are one fifth there are five other
districts here and we have got a larger
proportion of small businesses and
medium-sized businesses than our fair
share
that must suggest that we're an
attractive place to do business
so i'm not going to say
normally waffle on but i'm not going to
stop there because i just think credit
to mr buckland and his team for the
environment they've created in stratford
district is encouraging residents
developers and businesses to operate in
this district
uh thank you councillor curtis
thank you chair um
just picking up some of the points about
the finances going forward and the
report on creating south warwickshire
council i'm sure we're all very
concerned about the finances of the
council going forward
the report suggests that annual savings
in excess of four and a half million
could be made
by bringing the council together i'm
emphasizing the could
but this still leaves the best estimates
an annual shortfall
in 2526
of 5 million pounds
um
given that this there are now rumors
circulating probably quite well
substantiated that this conservative
government
is going to cut
funding for local authorities by a
further 12 and a half percent
i am very concerned as to what further
cuts the authority is going to have to
make to meet that 5 million pound
shortfall going forward thank you
thank you members i'll um i'll try to
pick up uh as many of those points as i
can um i'll i'll go in reverse order uh
with councillor curtis and councillor
curtis would have seen a response to a
question i don't comment on rumors and i
also have in front of me councillor
harvey who uh if i if if i or this
cabinet started
making predictions about
um few the future finances of this
organization without some robust
evidence base um i would be put firmly
in my place um you talk
absolutely correctly angela curtis about
the significant challenges that local
government face
uh and i think we all should remember
how much we are actually delivering up
and down the country as the as the local
government family in the in the in the
teeth of some really challenging times
uh and there is
there is a question of savings and can i
just say just for the avoidance of that
these are not savings that are going to
result in some
miraculous sort of rebate for anybody or
anything like that
this is money that we need to be able to
find better ways to spend so that we can
continue to deliver the services that
our residents
wishes to deliver and by coming together
as two authorities we have the best
possible opportunity to continue to
deliver those services that we all want
to deliver regardless of what party
political badge or non that we wear um
so i i'm familiar firmly in the place
that that that is a a must do there is
an awful lot of work to do and there are
there are still pieces of work to do as
we move through the next few years to
ensure that the
the finances of the authority are
sufficiently robust to enable us to
deliver the services that our residents
want us to deliver um
uh counsellors junied uh foy check uh
and particularly
a number of others also talked about
housing um there is data about uh the
the sort of split between the various
tenures for
uh what falls under the broad heading of
social housing and i recall actually
leading the best value regroup
review group back in the early 2000s
that established the 35 percent so um i
i i am absolutely in the place that says
we need to ensure that we can deliver
homes uh for our residents um
to living that they can afford and they
can make their home in the long term uh
what i will commit to is um to ensure
that uh uh a a a briefing note is
sent for members to show the the splits
of various tenures in terms of where we
build the houses of course we're we're
informed by things such as neighborhood
development plans neighborhood housing
surveys
and the housing team
work very very closely with our partner
parish and town councils to ensure that
there is the best match between delivery
and need and is it a perfect science uh
no it isn't uh but we are absolutely
clear on why we we need to do you know
to deliver houses where people need them
in terms of vacant homes you're right we
have about 2 300 vacant
i have one in my own ward and i can i
can i can only observe
that it is a hugely long and and winding
process so ultimately you're potentially
talking about taking a property out of
private ownership into public ownership
i i take the point about the housing
association and my colleague councillor
barker has regular discussions with with
our housing association partners to
ensure that they maintain their stock
and you know that when it becomes vacant
it's turned over quickly we will
continue to press that and i will ask
councillor barker to continue to push on
that
uh and uh and clearly there may be
opportunities to update members further
on that in the future but it is you know
it is quite a torturous process but
the thick end of two and a half thousand
homes that if we could bring them back
in would be something i would welcome
but but as i say i wouldn't criticize
our officers uh because it is it is a
tortuous process
um yes we have a wide variation in fuel
poverty uh
we have a wide variation in lots of
things across our district but i i
understand that in terms of the kovic
response i wasn't entirely sure what uh
cancer junior was was looking for i mean
clearly there is going to be
some form of national inquiry at some
point
and undoubtedly that will pick up on um
the input from local government i think
local government rose to the challenge
stupendously
um and i under i i am and the local
government association will also be
pressing that so i think in terms of
um absolutely lessons to be learned uh
but what i would probably ask is that uh
we think about being focused about what
we're we're going to look at uh and
perhaps that's something we can we can
revisit in in the future counselor
fragile asked about schools and
obviously clearly
county right point on that um
as this authority we we we continue to
have briefings from public health
england the chief exec continues to
provide members with briefings i think
we're all aware um that we are in a
challenging place at the moment and we
must all keep our fingers crossed that
we managed to get through
this winter uh i was listening to
something earlier today you know about
the you know how how the the importance
of the booster jab is going to be uh so
i think there's a lot of things that we
need to do to there but yes we're aware
and i think the county of ryden point on
that
different communities take different
views i hear what you say about pads
though i think we are encouraging a
climate for people to be
safe respectful of others around things
such as wearing a mask and things like
that
and i think we are trying to give
positive messages out there uh and uh
our business owners um i think uh are
you know should look to take the
those on board um nigel you are you are
a very bad counselor rock i do apologize
so we that's slipping back into those
briefings there councillor rock you are
balanced you give with one hand and you
take with the other uh as far as open
reach is concerned i as i am my
understanding is that's the work that uh
councillor cargill is leading on around
a rural broadband um and looking at
councillor cargill i'm sure he would be
delighted to give you uh a briefing on
our on on our on our uh pressing of
uh bt openreach uh to uh to improve upon
a uh a piece of string and two baked
bean tins as our broadband service
provision
um
so i i think what again we'll probably
look i'll i'll look to see if we'll look
to if we can put a briefing note
together for members i think it is an
ongoing thing there for for for for all
of us um
and i think finally the um thing was
around um uh the core plan um
for a lot of members in this room that
that predates you we we had and still
have a core strategy
that we as a sort of corporate body of
members
went through uh the the officers uh
provided an evidence base we came to a
an approach which was a dispersed
approach uh so to some degree we've we
that's that's that is it is therefore no
surprise that the
there is a the development has been
focused particularly around the main
rural centres
um going back to lessons learned as
you're aware we're going into uh a new
south warwickshire plan process
and absolutely we will be
learning some of those lessons
and i'm just going to put it right out
there i i
am personally of the view
that
a continued approach solely around
extending our current
settlements
does bring with it challenges around the
appropriate level of infrastructure and
given that given that we have to provide
for the homes that we all know that
people need and for them to be
affordable to provide for the jobs that
we all need to support the people who
are living in the affordable homes and
to have a green infrastructure to ensure
that we meet our climate change
objectives
we will need development
you know and we will need to find a
mechanism that enables us to do that uh
without some of the law of unintended
consequences
but i do share as a number of members do
concern uh around the you know the
dispersal so um but that will be
something that will come through in the
evidence base uh and we'll all debate
that in a few months time and we'll all
come to a landing as to what is the best
way to take the plan forward
and once we've done so we're we're on
that train uh i think that probably
covers everybody's points um if i've
missed anything no
no doubt somebody will tell me offline
what if i've missed something
counselors
i don't know whether i could just give a
point of information but um the report
that was produced by the select
committee chaired by jeremy hunt
is well worth looking at
sorry through youtube i just wasn't
quite sure what you you were
specifically asking us
everybody's
i think everybody's aware of that
particular report so thank you
councillor juned um i think other than
that it's um the recommendation is as on
page 27.
thank you and the state of the district
um it's just a report for for noting so
thank you councillors for
your contribution there
uh item eight the electoral review of
the stratford and haven district council
i would now like to invite david
buckland as chief executive uh to
introduce this report
good afternoon council
before i get going on this report i just
want to make sure that all counsellors
have got all the different pieces of
information they'll need this afternoon
to consider this particular item so we
have on the printed agenda itself a
report that was published alongside the
agenda that's on page 57 of the report
of the agenda pack
on wednesday last week there was a an
additional supplement
published
and that a hard copy thank you very much
councillor parker demonstrating that a
hard copy was on your desk as well
and this morning there was an
extraordinary meeting of the audit and
standards committee
and you should have a copy of the
minutes from this morning's audit and
standards committee also on your desk
i think i'd like to stay by by stating
that there seems to be
ah seems to be there is a
misunderstanding of the council's
position in release relation to this
particular review
the audit sorry the local government
boundary commission for england
published their proposals in late
recommendations sorry in late august for
the future awarding arrangements of the
district
at paragraph 33 within that document
they state
explicitly that the council has not
asked for a review on this occasion
using single member awards
that isn't the position of council that
isn't the position that we we made our
submission on when we formally
considered the council size in december
2020 and we did include a statement
within that council side submission that
we wish to review to be on single member
wards
we had a meeting of the electoral review
working group which was held
on the 4th of october at that meeting i
was urged to write immediately to the
local government boundary commissioner
for england stating that the review has
not been undertaken in line with the
wishes of council
i've engaged with the chief executive of
julian jackson at the boundary
commission
and have received a response to that
which states that we did not formally
state
in a separate submission or receive a
separate resolution of council that that
was the basis for which we wanted the
review to be undertaken
in constructive dialogue with the
boundary commission we've agreed a
two-pronged attack as to how potentially
we can resolve this particular matter
the supplement that you have got the
supplement that i published on wednesday
last week
seeks to reaffirm the council's formal
position and the basis for which the
review should be undertaken i.e that it
would be undertaken on the basis of a
single member board review
it goes on to also request that the
boundary commission formally withdraws
its sets of proposals
and then reconsults on that particular
basis
there is no guarantee that the boundary
commission will
accept or change their view as a result
of that resolution if council does
resolve in that particular position this
afternoon
or indeed abandon the current round of
consultation
therefore the other approach that julian
jackson also suggested is that we
robustly respond to the current set of
recommendations now that robust response
is the subject of the second piece of
information that you have this afternoon
in relation to the audit and standards
committee who have considered in detail
recommendations that came forward from
the electoral review working group last
friday at another meeting extraordinary
meeting to consider the recommendations
and to prepare a response for the
electoral commission on that basis
one of the responses that the electoral
commission could make
in receipt of such a strong rebuttal of
the current recommendations is that they
could take the proposals back
reconsider them and actually restart a
further round of consultation
i'm not a betting man
but i believe that would be the approach
that the commission would take if we
agree both of these resolutions this
afternoon
very conscious that you've had
information landing on your desk this
afternoon and then in discussion with
the chairman felt it might be
appropriate just for a short adjournment
of say 10 minutes so that you can fully
read all the information that you have
in front of you
okay thank you so meeting adjourned for
10 minutes
one minute please counselors we've got
one minute please
shall we
go thank you councillors
i'd now like to invite um chief
executive david buckland to uh continue
thank you chairman um
so the first item that we're going to be
considering as council this afternoon
will be the supplement that was
published last wednesday i feel it is
very important that we resolve the issue
in relation to
fully understanding the position of
council in relation to the basis of the
review
so the first paper deals firstly with
the
basis and asking for council to affirm
or not that he wanted the review to be
undertaken on a single member ward
review basis
subject to recommendation one
move on to say well on that basis the
current proposal recommendations don't
reflect that and therefore requesting
that the boundary commission withdraw
their current uh consultation exercise
thank you um may i please introduce a
reintroduce uh deputy leader aaron
pemberton
thank you champ um
the chief executive has summarized the
purpose of the paper um the
recommendation
um enables us as a council to formally
record our position and that the current
review for wards for stratford and naval
district council are based on the
principle of single member awards and
that secondly on that basis and subject
to the agreement of recommendation one
the council agrees that the council's
position in relation to single member
awards should be reported immediately
to the local government boundary
commission for england and alongside
that that there is a formal request that
the current consultation exercise be
withdrawn on the basis that it is not
based on the principle of single member
wards so members i i am proposing those
two recommendations which i think hang
together and we should take as a single
rather than vote individually i am
getting a nod of ascent from uh the
legal officer and the chief executive so
we'll take both recommendations as one
so i'm looking for uh someone to second
that and i have councillor rock to
second that uh i apologize i have my
field of vision uh but so that's
seconded by councillor rock um
anybody wish to speak or does anybody or
should we just move straight to the vote
i think we move to the to the vote
and then the proposals from this morning
okay thank you so those in favor please
put your cards
in the air
thank you councillors that's unanimous
um
so we
okay uh councillor crump
thank you mr chairman um this morning we
had as you rightly said we have the meet
the extraordinary
meeting of audit and standards committee
um
where
we came up with two recommendations that
we would like the council to consider
they've all been sent out um
the two recommendations are that the
council strongly objects to the local
government boundary commission for
england's current recommendation and
formally records its position that the
review should be based on single member
wards
and that notwithstanding the objection
the revised recommendations for 41
single member wards be considered as the
council's additional response to the
lgbce consultation and i
am proposing that if possible
uh thank you councillor dixon
thank you chairman i'm very happy to to
second that
recommendation
from the chairman of the audit and
standards committee and i think in order
to try and emphasize to the
lgbce i would like to request that we
have a named
vote i appreciate this will take a few
more moments than an ordinary raise of
the hands but i think it will emphasize
to the committee to the commission
exactly the feelings of this council and
hopefully everybody will feel able to
say yay we support this recommendation
oh thank you councillor photchick
point of clarification um just don't
understand what this process is i
thought we just voted on it so if you
could just clarify that for me
chairman i'm happy to take that
particular point council has just
resolved that it wishes the review to be
undertaken based on single memory awards
and that will be the representation that
i've already drafted and hopefully now
it's on its way to the boundary
commission for them to consider at their
meeting which they're holding tomorrow
as i explained in the introduction
there's no guarantee that the boundary
commission will withdraw its current
round of consultation based upon the
resolution that council has just made
and therefore the second approach the
second prong
that the boundary commission has
recommended is that we do respond to the
current round of consultation in
relation to the recommendations and the
um recommendations that have come
through from the extraordinary meeting
of the audit and standards committee
that councillor crump has just
introduced actually
is the council's response to that
particular exercise for clarity
when the um boundary commission
consulted there were 29 single member
awards and six double member awards the
proposals have been considered by the
electoral review group and then endorsed
this morning by the audience standing
committees this
responds well reverts back to the
recommendations from this council being
that there should be 41 single member
wards
i'm now looking for a second uh for the
recorded vote thank you councillor rocco
would you like to speak
i was just interning to speak chairman
on a point of clarification with this
war this work the wording of the warding
um
and because this was done in the context
of the earlier meeting
uh in the
the revive the revised recommendation
for 41 single member wards which i think
we're saying is this
piece of paper
i don't think that's entirely clear from
this
this
wording
uh as long as we all understand that is
what we are voting for i think that's
just worth
clarifying
uh chairman
perhaps mr buckland could comment on
that
one thing i don't want is any more
ambiguity on this review so if there is
ambiguity we can make it clear that they
are the set of recommendations proposed
by the electoral review working group
and we can incorporate that into the
into the minute
thank you
thanks and i'm looking for a second uh
verb
thank you councillor cargill
sorry chairman we there it was a
proposed from councillor dixon that
there be a
named vote just checking councillor
cargill second in that request
thank you
since i announced that there were eight
apologies we've had one further apology
councilman bromwich is also absent this
afternoon so councilman
um sorry i thought councillor dixon
seconded the second one
did you know no councillor dixon um has
suggested a named vote all right
i believe councillor dixon did both to
be confusing i think council dixon
seconded the recommendations but also
called for a named vote councillor
cargill has now seconded the call for a
named vote
so
council we we i will be calling your
name we are taking both recommendations
together if when i call your name you
could please indicate whether you are
for against or obscene for the
recommendations from the extraordinary
meeting of the audit and standards
committee this morning i will start with
chairman
councillor
vice chairman councillor dixon
councillor dixon four thank you uh
councillor adam
councillor adam four thank you uh
councillor cog councillorcock4
thank you um councillor barker
councillor barker iv thank you um
councillor bomage is absent councillor
cargill councilcargill4 thank you um
councillor crump
that's the crop for
thank you uh councillor curtis
thank you councillor fielding
that's the field
thank you um councillor fleming
councillor fleming for
thank you um council uh poetic
councillor foytec iv
thank you councillor foreman
thank you councillor
um ian frankly
councillor ian fraser
thank you councillor jenny frenchly
thank you um councillor harvey
thank you councillor junid
thank you councillor kettle
thank you councillor mills council meals
for
thank you councillor parry
thank you
councillor pemberton councillor
pemberton for
thank you councillor peter keller
councilor per tagalog four
thank you councillor richards that's
richard's four
thank you uh councillor riley
anthony riley four thank you
um councillor rock
councillor rock four thank you
councillor wolfe councillor rolf iv
thank you councillor shenton
councillor shanton
thank you
um and councillor
wally hoggins
councillor wally hoggins four
thank you chairman i'll make that
unanimous with 20 votes for seven votes
for
okay thank you so that is uh resolved
uh moving on to
item nine which is the change of scheme
of delegations in relation to planning
decisions i invite councillor parry the
portfolio holder for planning to
introduce this report
thank you chairman um
this report
is a proposal to amend the scheme of
delegations
i'm gonna have to put my glasses on
excuse me
to planning
decisions where the status of an
application changes
once published on the planning committee
agenda
in other words
when the reasons for triggering an
application coming before the planning
committee have actually fallen away
for ease of explanation
this actually is perhaps because parish
council town council
or ward member
has actually withdrawn
their objection or support
under the current procedure
which those members of the planning
committee will be well aware
the case officer still has to attend
put a planning presentation together
and provide
you know a lot of expertise
um
in order for it to then be delegated
with the planning committee's approval
for a decision anyway
so race in a nutshell what this actually
does
is short-circuit a procedure that
automatically happens at the planning
committee
and this will only apply
where the reasons for the application
being referred to committee have
actually fallen away
since the agenda was published so it is
it is a procedural thing it
short-circuits it
um and you will all be aware of the very
high case loads that the planning
officers currently have
and by supporting these these
recommendations
for for approval
what you're actually doing is certainly
freeing up some time for the planning
case officers to actually focus more of
their attention on those planning
applications that need to come before
committee
it would all happen to have with the
chairman of planning committee's
approval
he is in favor of these recommendations
and therefore that i ask you to approve
these recommendations which you'll find
on page 115
of your report thank you chair thank you
uh councillor bertogallo
yeah thank you chair and i'm not
completely happy with these
recommendations and i think one
the question that we need to ask
ourselves is why are we having this late
withdrawals
shouldn't be better communication
between
the officers and world members and
parish councils um
there is a process already in place
um and if that process is followed then
we you know
the conversation between officers and
what board members and parish councils
then we wouldn't have these late
withdrawals so i'm just not
happy about um
the the this scheme of delegation in
this particular instance
thank you um we'll just i've got a
question from councillor ian for
actually as well
thank you chair
if a stratfor town council and the
planning officer have a different view
on a particular planning application
then the planning officer often comes
back to the town council to see if there
are any adjustments which could be made
in order for the final decision to be
made by delegated authority rather than
being deferred to the planning committee
could you confirm that this arrangement
will be preserved within this proposal
thank you um council clemson did you
want to speak before
[Music]
thank you i was just going to
to observe and comments that
um
the dialogue between uh playing officers
ward members and parish and town
councils
is always close and there are
legitimate reasons why a parish or town
council may wish to withdraw
their
objections
and that may be as a result of the kind
of discussions that counselor fragile
has
highlighted
and there is nothing in this
to suggest that that practice and
process will change in any way shape or
form
i think the reality is that if there are
um there are on occasion um
applications that come
and the committee is hearing the full
detail and presentation of an
application
in the in the knowledge that the the
reason for the committee having been
brought together to make a decision on
that particular application is for
example uh an objection by a parashor
town council if that objection is no
longer there it does not seem to be
the most useful time
spent by by the committee considering
that uh bearing in mind the number of
applications that do come to committee
and members want the commit the planning
committees to give
the applications the most right proper
and appropriate scrutiny i think
anything that enables them to focus on
the issues they need to focus on
and speaking as a former chair of the
planning committee and a former planning
development portfolio holder i see this
nothing more than a tidying up exercise
i don't see it as anything
it's talking about expense it's
technically expanding the scheme of
delegation but it is just about
being sensible and taking a pragmatic
approach i think the reality is that
if there were any suggestion that a town
or parish council felt it had been
sidelined perhaps in the manner that
might have been alluded to i think that
the portfolio holder uh would would get
to learn that very very quickly indeed
so um i think we can do this with quite
a lot of comfort thank you
council rock
thank you chairman um
i'm slightly torn about what
what has been said because it what has
just been said both by the portfolio
holder and council of pemberton
actually i agree with because i i the
words on the page
are actually fine
but
that's a pertugeles point is a good one
as to
why we seem to have quite a lot of
what
these
said differences have been found out and
he eliminated
a bit late
in the process so we end up with the
report being written in and all the
things that we're trying to resolve
so
i'm actually happy to support this
providing we go back and try and
understand why that is occurring and i
think there is a bit of an issue with
communication which is sort of built in
now you know
the number of applications i get is in
the top five as is uh councillor
pertiguellas so this is to be frank has
happened two or three times in my ward
where there's
things that take a bit of time to get
resolved right at the last minute as it
were and the report has to be written
and come forward and all the sort of
things we're concerned about
what we're going to ask ourselves is is
why has that happened
there's quite a lot of diff with ward
members it's not so bad because we can
have a conversation and we tend to be
able to get hold of the officers been
quite difficult during
covid but now we've got ms teams we can
see the officers there and all the rest
of it
parish councils haven't got find it a
bit harder to do that for instance some
of my parish councils only have two
monthly they may not delegate uh
permissions to the clerk to be able to
do all that sort of thing so i think
there is a there's a bit of a challenge
there and i think we could perhaps work
on that i'm happy to support this but i
think we might go away and work on
actually improving the communication
exactly as cancer pertiga has said to
try and see why is we get to those late
ones and understanding how that occurs
so i think the point is well made in in
both directions so i'm i'm trying to be
sensible and objective thank you
chairman
thank you council parish you want to
make a quick comment
more counsellors
thank you chair and i'd like to actually
thank councillor bertie geller and
councillor rock for their contributions
on this can i just give you some
reassurance that i will raise it with
the planning manager anyway to see what
we can do to improve the communication
side between case officers and parish
and ward members just so happens
actually i've actually got an email from
a case officer on a particular
application in my ward highlighting an
appeal judgment on something that's come
back and that that those sorts of things
can make a difference when in fact you
know it's all at the end of the day it's
all down to communication but you both
make very valid points and i'll take
them on board thank you thank you
councillor riley
thank you chair
um i have uh three questions about this
firstly are are there any statistics on
um
past cases um which will indicate how
frequently this facility
will be used if it's agreed
um
the second point i wanted to make was
which has been touched on by um
some of my colleagues was
uh parish councils
um i used to serve on one and our
council and parish council only met
monthly but i was aware that quite a few
others met less frequently than that
that's the sort of cycle time that the
parish council takes to change its mind
because something can be resolved at one
meeting
there won't be another one for at least
a month and that's
quite a long time
in between you know
decisions and if you like
um
so
yes um i'm wondering how often this
happens
given how long it takes for paris
councilman to change his mind
um the other
thing i wanted to ask was will there be
any oversight in the use of this
facility to see how well it's working
uh because i have
whilst i might need to
support it i have misgivings that it
might be
used inappropriately
i think you think phils is going to come
in here
thank you
thank you chairman um if we could all
just look at paragraph 1.2.1
it kind of neatly summarizes what the um
mischief is if i can put it like that
and it is it is solely if you imagine it
we've got to position where the the
views of the
let's say the parish council and the
officer
are different so it's been put on the
agenda
for a planning meeting
and then at some point
after that but before the meeting
the position of the parish council
changes
at that point in time
the officer might not have or
not have actually
prepared the report and the presentation
and it's trying to save that really
because at the moment what happens is
in any event
the the officer has to attend the
meeting even though the parish council
might have changed their position
between the publication of the agenda
and the meeting the officer has to
prepare
the report the presentation go there
only for the planning committee then to
delegate it back to the offices so
that's the mischief it's trying to solve
it's not trying to do anything more than
that
um if that helps
oh thank you i don't know if councillor
power wants to reply to that but then
we've got uh councillors barker and
fielding i think actually um the
monitoring officer encapsulated
everything very very straightforward
it's a procedure it's not a difference
into what's gonna currently what's
currently happening at the moment it's
just a short circuit that procedure but
nothing happened it doesn't deviate from
the democratic process i think is the
point i'm trying to make
kel sparker
thank you when i first joined this
district council i had a habit of
objecting to all sorts of things in
shipston
um nobody told me i had to turn up at
the planning meetings until it was found
that reports were being written on my
behalf and i wasn't there and so exactly
that happened so that's one of the
things that happened one of the things
the other thing that's happened during
covid
is that i have a lot of parish councils
and i know that uh council woolly
hogan's agree with me because we hear
the same
rhetoric really from some of our
parishes where they want to see the hard
copy they no longer get sent the hard
copy they haven't been able to come in
to see an officer to look at the hard
copy particularly big plans which are
very hard to look at
on the computer and that is one of the
reasons that they have even more
problems than they might have already so
my personal view is that if it is
possible for the be more either a duty
planner or somebody in here on a daily
basis so that can be addressed that
would be most helpful
thank you uh counselor phil otherwise i
support castlefielding
thank you chairman um
i've been using teams a lot to get
through to the
offices by giving them the number that
i'm wanting to talk to they bring me
back and then we can have a proper
discussion i'm also a great advocate of
videos but i proposed may i propose that
we accept this report
um
and therefore
um
leave it at that
thank you councillor fielding councillor
kettle
thank you mr chairman
uh i support this proposal uh i was
going to just make one suggestion
and that is
um
ensure to ensure that there is a formal
recognition of the withdrawal of the
objection from either the parish or
effect with the ward member that there
is actually an agreed form of words that
the parish council might be required to
sign off
saying they do withdraw their objection
uh in the event there isn't anything in
writing if it's done verbally
so that we do just have a written audit
trail
so that the issues that
you have raised um
are sorted
thank you councillor richards thank you
if it helps you counselor kevin
obviously this you'll see in the report
this has to go through the head of
service and also the planning uh
committee chairman i i will be
requesting a clear audit trail so i can
see
in front of me that someone has
withdrawn either council or war member
has withdrawn their support or objection
thank you i now call for a seconder
please councillor ian shenson
um and if that's agreed i can is that
agreed
agreed wonderful thank you i can now
confirm
that's one moving on to item 10 we've
got the barely neighborhood development
plan and i invite councillor pemberton
as deputy leader of the council to
introduce this item
thank you chairman uh
how you have before your recommendation
that the barely neighborhood development
plan um is adopted with immediate effect
which will give the consequence that it
becomes part of the development plan for
stratford-upon-avon districts
and therefore
a key document in relation to
managing
the assessment of planning applications
in beerly
the
barely neighborhood development group
have worked
tirelessly to produce this document
in conjunction with our policy team
officers and first of all i would like
to thank them for their hard work in
bringing what is an excellent document
that will help
support appropriate development for
burley will give good and clear guidance
to our officers and clarity to to uh the
uh the elected representatives in barley
the referendum had a resounding 89.8
yes vote
um on a turnout of 38 which uh members
will know is quite quite high as far as
neighbourhood development plan referenda
are concerned so with all of that and i
know that uh um councillor shenzhen
would like to uh echo thanks i imagine
i
am looking then for a second to the
recommendation on page 119
uh and thank you
pemberton yeah i just wanted to uh to
record my thanks to everyone involved in
this plan um
really it's been a number of years in
the making and um
oh sorry my apologies
uh so it's been a number of years in the
making and um
obviously for them this is an important
moment uh i was with
uh
baby brooklyn on on the the night of the
count and uh i was pleasantly surprised
at the turnout and at the
the yes vote so my thanks go to everyone
involved in this and i would gladly
thank you is that agreed
wonderful
so items referred to the council from
other committees um item point 11 we've
got minute 216 notion of motus uh
so we've got the notice of motion south
warwickshire foundation trust and i'd
like to invite councillor barker
portfolio holder for homes health and
well-being to introduce this item
i would just like to point you to page
121
and
more importantly the second paragraph
which encapsulates perfectly what's
going on at the moment with
swift on this particular issue
um
that there is a review of non-acute bed
provision and
the looking at the policy of discharge
to access but there was no consultation
exercise under wet person there still
isn't a consultation process therefore
um the cabinet were minded to
reject the notice of missions
thank you counselor junaid
uh yes as i understand it they called it
a survey rather than a consultation but
but uh as i understand it a consultation
will follow i i would like to seek
reassurance that when that consultation
does come as it inevitably will um that
the council uh does look to put forward
a position thank you
councillor junior you will not be
disappointed
thank you and i'll look for a seconder
please
counselor harvey
and if that's is that an agreement
yeah wonderful thank you
item 12 the development requirements
supplementary planning document spd and
part w gypsies and travelers and
travelling show people
council of pemberton
thank you chairman um you have before
you
the
minute217
which looks to adopt part w gypsy and
travelers and travelling show people of
the development requirements
supplementary planning document um this
has been through a technical process
including stakeholder and public
consultation
to enable us to to make some further uh
movement towards uh addressing how we
meet the needs of uh gypsies travelers
and travelling show people uh for for
sites across this district um
the recommendation is that the um the
spd be uh
sorry the part w be adopted as part of
the development requirements
supplementary planning document um
members can see before them the key
parts of the
of the document
there has been a removal on the section
of proximity to local services and local
thresholds
and equally there is also
the identification of the broad
locations
and we have also looked at some of the
design criteria in relation to ensuring
that
flooding and environmental and heritage
asset issues are
it's lost my words then for a second
which is hugely unusual
are addressed um members um happy to
take any questions uh other than that
um looking for a seconder to the
recommendation to council that uh this
be adopted as part of the uh
development requirements supplementary
planned document
thank you i'll take the second der
councillor barca there uh councillor
peter keller
thank you chairman thank you councilor
pemberton for uh um presenting this
important document
now i'm noticing regarding lighting
in the spd there is no reference to dark
skies
and several villages in rural areas have
dark skies policies and we know that
dark skies have a positive impact on
biodiversity
so i'd like to make a request
that lighting
should also include a consideration for
the dark sky policies of rural areas and
settlements in the district
thank you
thank you councillor taguelo um the
absence of a specific reference to dark
skies policies should not be taken uh as
any indication that darkstars policies
would not be adhered to where they are
in place um i think it it
it we have to con
this has to be taken in the round in
conjunction in connection with with
other planning documents i will however
take your comment uh and i'm sure
through uh councillor parry development
colleagues will will ensure that they
dot that item across that particular t
uh i i don't see a need at the uh to
revise the document and and take it back
through uh a process for that it the
absence of it is is not indicative that
that would not be adhered to so i i hope
that with that
um
confirmation and reassurance that uh
councillor pettigella will be happy to
support uh the spd thank you
thank you do we have any more questions
is everyone in agreement there
agreed
thank you thank you uh item
point 13 uh minute 218 the draft
sustainable home sustainable communities
housing strategy for stratfor native and
district from 2021 to 2026 i'd like to
invite councillor barker to introduce
this item
this is minute 218 the job of
sustainable homes etc
and housing strategy
cabinets
uh
was uh minded to
endorse the strategy and to recommend to
council that that's exactly what we do
uh we're not just in dorset sorry we
adopted um and we do consider and i i
take into account very much what
councillor junaid says here and thinks
in terms of sustainable homes and
sustainable communities should enable
more people to live independently in
good quality homes of their choice i
completely and utterly endorse that and
then with with my housing hat on
um doing exactly that and more so across
the district is my aim um so you will be
hearing more about this but at the
moment what i can say to you is can i
please recommend that we adopt the 2021
to 2026 strategy thank you
thank you councillor junaid
i i welcome that assurance because um it
is personal experience within my ward
the difficulty when
somebody either doesn't drive has a
caring experience particularly for
elderly parents or has a child with
special educational needs there's a
variety of reasons why they need to stay
in their community
and their provision of houses are not
always where um where
it suits that person to be within their
community
and so as long as it is accepted that
community networks are valuable uh that
people and families being able to uh uh
support each other are accepted and then
i have no problems with that it is
that's my particular great my particular
experience about making sure that people
stay networked with their communities
thank you uh following councillor
parker's proposal please may i have a
seconder
councillor pemberton who's first there
we didn't ask like to speak item
okay we all in agreement
there thank you
item 14 minute 219 the capital budget
monitoring uh please may i welcome
councillor harvey to speak
thank you mr chairman
this is a straightforward recommendation
to council
the council has entered into contractual
arrangements to provide
leisure services and refuse collection
facilities
and in order to fulfill its side of the
contract it needs to borrow money up to
them the amount of 9 million pounds
the key question is on what terms is
this money to be borrowed and the answer
is
it will be borrowed by the council from
the public works loan board and it will
be supplied
to the count to the other parties in the
subject of the contract at a higher rate
so there is provided these organizations
don't go out of business um there is
there is a margin built in for the uh
for the councils so on on that basis i
put this recommendation and call for a
second
thank you councillor kettle second that
uh councillor juned
it is just a matter of clarification um
the paragraph above the recommendation
seems to indicate uh that the money is
for leisure contract
and the refuse vehicles and food caddies
whereas the recommendation
seems to indicate that that is only for
the refuse collection vehicles and food
caddy have i misread that it could you
just clarify on that please
happy to do that um
the intention is to supply
finance or kit
for the
leisure centers to improve standard
facilities and services that's provided
to people who use our alleged facilities
as well as fund
up to 5 million pounds for the
refuge collection
so i think you're right in pointing it
out and i'm sure that that clarification
can be built in
thank you are there any further
questions
are we in agreement
yeah thank you everyone um item 15
minutes 287 the service integration and
accommodation uh council pemberton
thank you thank you chairman um
the purpose of of this
minute is
to seek confirmation from council
in relation to the uh process of
continued service integration
and a move towards looking for joint
accommodation for for officers and
members of strafford and avon and
warwick district councils irrespective
of the outcome of any process towards
political merger members will be aware
that a joint advisory steering group
was set up that group has met in july
and september
and some supported the the
recommendations uh and so therefore
members
this is seeking council's confirmation
are that we continue down the the
journey of integrating uh our services
and our teams um irrespective of the
decision that we will likely take in
december around any potential political
merger so the recommendation is that
work has progressed on the full service
integration of teams across stratford
and naval and warwick district councils
that work is progressed on the advent
identification of sharing civic and
office accommodation between stratford
and warwick district councils and
certainly on the latter the answer to
the question is no i don't know
thank you councillor juned
i'll seek your second or sorry
there are many reasons um why an
integration of office accommodation um
is beneficial for things like climate
change energy efficiency savings uh for
changing um dramatically changing ways
of working for staff what i'm
particularly concerned about though is
that i want would like to see
consideration taken into the picture and
into the building built into the work
plan that there are
many people who uh who
for a variety of reasons um are not able
to go online who prefer face-to-face
meetings and for some people that would
mean traveling and for some people
traveling to an area where the bus
routes just do not go would be difficult
or where maybe the cars um where it's
difficult to get to so what i'm asking
for is that consideration is taken into
into account of that and that making
sure that there is the ability to
develop hubs or the ability to develop
uh regional local um ways of residents
being able to keep in touch with their
council being able to take up their
problems face-to-face are properly
considered and that as a way of going
forward we we embrace the technological
of the
experience coming forward
which will be very very different in
years to come but always remembering
that some of our residents will not be
able to uh work within that and that we
will always consider that
uh thank you councillor cargill
if i may pick that up
thank you for that and
you're absolutely right
when we started this process
a number of years ago now
we we estimated that we would have
accommodation with perhaps 70 percent
occupancy
while covid pushed that down
dramatically and they're probably near a
40
occupancy which means that we can
release
assets like elizabeth and riverside
house
that brings its own challenges
of course well you've mentioned now
about having
contact with our arizonans and to me
that's one of the most important
elements of this whole thing we don't
want to lose touch with our residents
and i will be looking as part and parcel
of my portfolio is to look at the best
way we can accommodate that
i also have other ideas i'll be bringing
forward to this particular group
but your other point
we also recognize completely that some
people will be quite happily working
from home all the time
some will be wanted to come in the
office all the time and then it's going
to be others in between we must
accommodate all of those as well
so
all of the above we will be looking at
those things
but rest assured that we will be
absolutely focused on how we and our
representation for our our communities
as well the best possible way thank you
chair thank you thank you councillor and
just confirm you are seconding
that as well
thank you any further questions
councillors
fantastic queen agreement
thanks
um
matters for noting by the council uh
urgent reports uh these are just for
noting we've got the uh the key
decisions published without notice due
to the urgency in accordance with the
constitution part four rules of
procedure 1810 so we've got the
temporary arrangements for domestic
recycling collections
we've got local authority delivery
scheme
and we've got the award of waste
collection contract okay moving on to
part 17 council's questions
um so we've got 16 questions being
received and these have been circulated
to you all on a separate sheet
um please just raise your hand if you
haven't got them there we can get some
to you
know look so everyone's got them
uh so all members asking questions we'll
have the opportunity to ask uh one super
much question uh questions one and two i
don't have a supplementary thank you uh
counselor rock do you have a
supplementary question
you did that very quickly chairman i
wasn't quite ready with my march thank
you very much indeed well first of all
um i thank the leader who of course is
absent for his positive response to my
question
um and i also thank uh the expressions
of support i've received from everybody
in this council for the sad plight of uh
uh
the the relatives of
nazaneez zarya radcliffe who live in my
ward which is very much appreciated
thank you very much indeed
i just wondered if uh
with that positive support
given that we have two influential
members of parliament that
serve
our district i wondered if that their
names might be added to uh if you like a
target for that if i can call it
lobbying perhaps that's not the right
word but asking for their support as
well uh i think that would be extremely
useful thank you very much indeed for
everybody's support
absolutely happy to support you and the
the relatives of nazim zaghari ratcliffe
in your ward
to ensure that the representation that
we make
to central government
is is also directed to
our two mps across the district
thank you council adam do you have a
supplementary question
i do thank you uh chairman um
thank you thank you to the portfolio
holder for the response i've had i have
some concerns though because looking at
um the document actually submitted to uh
this agenda under item seven uh for the
state of the district um it does seem to
contradict the answer that i've had from
him uh particularly in relation to the
assertion that
um the excessive development occurred
pre-core strategy when actually there's
a very useful graph that suggests that
it's been much more recent than than
that and it is affecting our communities
um with that in mind
uh
with the portfolio holder please
recognize that this is a current issue
affecting our
um our communities
um not just mine but many across this
council irrespective of uh political um
representation and that
a more immediate solution is required so
as not to have those communities
adversely affected uh before
a new strategy uh can be implemented
thank you
thank you councillor adam um i i don't
agree that there's an inconsistency i
would point out
that there is typically a significant
time lag between planning applications
uh being made
decisions being approved typically in
the run-up to
2016 when the core strategy was signed
off by the planning inspectorate in my
own ward
200 homes were approved the week that
the planning inspector approved and
signed off the court strategy
and the planning inspector a different
planning inspector in that same week
opined that this authority did not have
a five-year housing land supply and
councillor adam you and i are absolutely
on the same page here
but there are things out with our
control and the vast majority of the
unintended consequences
of development
in a number of our main rural centers
lies
in relation to applications uh
granted prior to the adoption of the
core strategy that are now coming on
stream and also um some decisions of her
majesty's planning inspectorate um yet
again in my own ward quite recently and
uh one to start to feel as though
perhaps
one's not liked by the planning
inspectorate we are on the same page
here
we have a robust strategy we
must remember that there is a
presumption towards development built
into the planning regime
we will
our officers
will support uh ward members in
resisting inappropriate development when
there are good planning grounds to do so
um if
that is not the case then members can be
robust and are robust in
persuading planning committees but
ultimately the planning inspectorate
makes some of these decisions um
i accept that we have had some of the
law of unintended consequences but
frankly the best thing that we can do is
to move to a new south wales plan
that will enable us to do some of the
things we really want to do around
climate change and embedding that in
that we can't do as much of now
so the answer lies in a new plan and if
mr carefort is watching um we we do need
to crack on with that i keep telling him
that the the the timeline needs to be
shorter than he comes to me with but we
will all get there very very quickly i
hope and so you can have the assurance
that i i understand what you say
but that is the answer let's get to a
new plan as soon as we possibly can
thank you
thank you uh question five counselor ian
fraser lee do you have a supplementary
question
not this time sharon thank you uh how
about for question six
uh thank you for the response
i do have a contact at um
it with foreign
there we go that's
lovely
that's fantastic thanks uh
count question seven councillor [ __ ] do
you have a supplementary question
nice i've made a question
thank you and for question eight
councillor cook
thank you question nine councillor jenny
frashley do you have a supplementary
question
just briefly i mean i did actually pose
this question on behalf of a number of
residents that are
increasingly upset about the um
empty properties around town i'm sure
other councillors are getting that from
their communities all i'd like to ask is
that we can pursue
as proactively as possible a resolution
to some of these larger properties which
at the moment are really beginning to
almost fall apart
and that we must take every action
and every avenue to actually find uh
repurpose these buildings thank you
thank you councillor perry
thank you councillor fragili and as
highlighted in my response to you the
enforcement team are looking at it and
it is it is a priority
thank you
thank you uh question 10 councillor roth
do you have a supplementary question
thank you uh question 11 counselor jenny
frashley do you have a supplementary
question
yes slightly disappointed with the
answer because i understand that
accessible stratford had been in
dialogue with the district um about the
changing places uh toilets
um
and there is the possibility of a site
so to miss out on on an opportunity to
actually put some place is disappointing
um
can i actually have an assurance i
understand that government money comes
forward with very very very tight uh
deadlines and may i actually have every
assurance that if money's come forward
for such a facility again that it is
acted on with sir alacrity thank you
thank you councillor jensen
uh i can assure you uh council approach
league that the answer to that is yes
the regulations are fairly new and i
will say that we do have
um
according to the the changing places uh
website we do have a one facility which
is at the leisure center um i know that
warwick and lemington only have one each
that's no excuse we will look into it um
and i will be in touch with mhclg about
future grants as well
thank you
question 13 councillor junet do you have
a supplementary question
no supplementary thank you thank you
question 14 councillor curtis do you
have a supplementary question yes thank
you chair um
thank you for the answer i'm sure this
uh
very carefully considered and succinctly
reply
from the portfolio holder will be a
great interest
to residents living in shoteri whose
lives have been blighted by this rumored
development
the last eight years or so
i recently asked the leader of the
council where the council should which
should withdraw support
for this so-called southwestern relief
road and he replied
it wasn't up to the council to withdraw
the application not actually my question
at the most recent cabinet meeting
southwestern relief road was again
raised and cabinet was reassured by
officers the stratfor district council
was liaising and communicating closely
with all parties concerned
the developers
county council and of course central
government
all parties concerned
except those most directly affected the
actual residents living in luddington
page 45 of our papers today says
council
will listen to and engage with residents
and communities and communities
use what we hear to shape what we do
find words but it seems this council
avoids giving answers that could offer
any clarification or reassurance i
believe residents deserve better
our papers also say on page 45
we will do what we can to contribute to
national carbon reduction targets
so my question is
how does port of the so-called relief
road which will destroy invaluable
natural habitats
remove much loved and well used green
open space to the west of the town and
increase traffic congestion and
pollution
help us meet our climate change targets
regarding climate change councilor
pemberton said earlier in today's
meeting
are we doing enough and quickly enough
no
that was his answer
we have a determination to make change
i suggest that one change that would
reassure residents that this council
takes climate change seriously would be
to withdraw support for this project and
seek a more environmentally sustainable
solution thank you
thank you council of pemberton
thank you chairman thank you council
curtis um
the sick nature of the response is
actually to help give some clarity to
um the residents of luddington in the
sense that
um
the article you know
there are you know there are rumors
there are comments
i think it is my role to try and provide
answers based on the facts that are in
front of me
the facts that are in front of me are
that there is a live planning
application to deliver the south west
relief road
there is not
a mechanism for us to
withdraw support
our support as a local planning
authority for that application
will be
initially by the planning officer
and undoubtedly given the nature and
complexity of this planning application
by a planning committee itself and that
is the proper place and time
for a decision to be made and
those decisions will take into account
our core strategy they will take into
account our wider climate change
emergency goals and it is right for the
those decisions to be taken in the right
place at the right time and that's a
really difficult thing for the residents
of ludington because frankly they they
want this wished away tomorrow and i
absolutely understand that but that is
not the place that we are in
um we have a live application um the
applicant were we to
take the course of action that
councillor curtis
looks for us to do
would be left then with the opportunity
to
make their case to a majesty's planning
inspector and i think
councillor curtis will have heard um my
response to councillor adam
and that will give you some sense of my
um
faith in her majesty's planning
inspectorate so there is an element
councillor curtis of be careful what you
wish for i absolutely understand
the concerns of the residents of
luddington we are where we are
if and when
there are changes to those facts on the
ground i will happily be open and
transparent
and as for the question of uh
transparency residents it is again about
the time you know so they will avoid
they've already commented on the
application they will undoubtedly get a
further element to it so yeah i just
want to try and stick to the facts if i
can and i understand why councillor
curtis quite rightly raises the matter
on behalf of his residents
thank you uh question 15 councillor rock
do you have a supplementary question
uh thank you chairman yes i do i think
portfolio as ever his comprehensive and
detailed reply
um
my question uh as i said in yes ministry
is wide-ranging um but i would like to
focus on one particular thing which is
about the
prospect of parish plans being replaced
by a uh enabled development plan on the
same subject
and there's always a learning point in
these uh
in these questions and i i thank the
portfolio holder for educating me on it
because up until they read this question
i i was unaware
that uh when
a parish plan was made after detailed
consultation and referendum and all that
sort of thing uh that the parish plan
continued in force all be 15 or 18 years
old
um therefore now we've found that that's
the case and if a parish wants the old
neighborhood plan to be extinguished by
the new naval development plan
would he consider it appropriate in the
naval development plan process
to point this information out to the
parish in question that their
neighborhood development plan would not
extinguish the old parish plan unless
they specifically ask it to do so
because there's certainly been confusion
in my ward about that
and as some of the questions and this
particular came to my attention to do
with finishes where the enabled
development plan was got quite different
requirements to the thing expressed in
the paris plan and yet the planning
committee proceeded then to use the
information from the parish plan
i think personally i think that was an
error and i think to avoid that
happening in future it would be a good
idea to advise parishes about that
because similar things could occur in
any of our parishes when they adopt and
make a parish
enabled development plan thank you
chairman
thank you chairman and thank you
councillor rock um
i'm going to let you into a secret
don't tell anybody else
but the hard yards and the hard work and
the detail that you have commended
before is actually produced and and
drafted in the first instance by our
officers uh really i i i i make that
point uh also you know just so that
members understand that there's an awful
lot of work that goes into
the production of
responding to answers to questions in a
relatively short time frame given how
questions come to you know in in in
relation to full council so um i would
like first of all to give a big shout
out to the officers because they do a
great job and they they they they're
really they they eat they can even me
mate look make me look good sometimes um
which is a big ask
specifically to answer your question
i'll ensure that uh policy officers do
just take that up from here on in and
just
ensure that there is that awareness
there going forward
thank you uh question 16 council purpose
aguila do you have a supplementary
question
yes thank you so uh thank you councillor
barker um i'm reassured that any
discussion on the future of um
the provision of shop mobility will
require full and i'd like to add
meaningful consultation with all parties
i did ask for a breakdown of the budget
um and i wonder whether a more detailed
breakdown could be
um
forwarded and circulated
for example what is the ten percent
covering general expenditure i think a a
breakdown of the budget of this service
will um help
uh with any uh future discussions uh on
its provision thank you
thank you councillor peter keller i will
ask the officers to break that down even
further but i would say that it
probably is boldly 90 10
not a very complicated budget when
you've just got staff and
had men and a few odds and swords which
you'd normally have
um but but if you want a further
breakdown if there is one you can have
it
okay lovely thank you everyone for your
questions and for the responses there
i'm gonna suggest we take break if
someone would agree with me just a very
short 10 minute one
yep
lovely so we'll be back
at 17 past four
because the kettle go and sit down
please
thank you meeting uh continued so we're
coming up now to questions to the leader
and i will shortly invite council of
pemberton as deputy leader to take
questions and absence of counselor
jefferson uh please remember we've got
two questions per member
with a maximum of three minutes for each
councillor please on matters that are
only to the responsibility
of this
council and i'm going to start my timer
because we've got 30 minutes for this
section as well that we can't go over
thank you councillor pemberton
projection did what
i love some stoppage time as well
right stoppage time uh thank you
councillor junior um
i i have um no idea whether the the lep
who are
sorry council the um the recording
doesn't seem to have restarted and teams
isn't on mute um
so have we recommenced and liz and
looking at the back
i think we can also kill it
thank you councillor junior do you want
to repose a question please
would the leader ask the lep uh local
enterprise partnership and shakespeare's
england what economic impact on
stratford can be expected from the
change that ended the ability for eu
citizens to travel to the uk using
national id cards from october that
first 2021
and particularly coming from those those
coming for regular school educational
trips and cultural exchanges who are
less likely to have passports and to put
that into context i believe it's 50 less
likely to have passports
one up here
is that any better
yes i swear yeah everybody can hear me
so it's clearly a lot worse thank you
councillor june for your forbearance
whilst i dance around the uh
uh the chamber looking for a microphone
that will work and not create a horrible
high-pitched wine um thank you
i i don't know whether uh the lep and or
shakespeare's england
have done any analysis or planned to do
i can ask the question
thank you
thank you uh councillor rob
um thank you um chair i had a very
interesting issue
brought to me uh last week by a resident
um when she applied for a green bin
uh you know seven months in
um from when it was first introduced and
she was charged 40 pounds
and i must admit um i kind of
agree with her i mean i i assumed it
would all be pro rata
um
but no it's not i mean i assume that you
pay for a bin
for a year from whenever you want it
um but um yeah i mean needless to say
she's not going to pay that 40 pounds
she's going to continue going
up to the tip which is a great shame um
i just wanted to really um
know where that was written down and was
that made very very specific in any
details because i've tried to look and i
haven't found it anywhere thank you
thank you councillor ralph and can i
also just welcome you back to the
chamber and
uh hope that you are feeling uh much
much better um uh you've been missed by
everyone in the in the chamber
regardless of their badge or none and um
i i hope that you will continue to be uh
um your usual self from here on in which
i will take as a sign that you are
firing on all cylinders
of course
of course
excellent
glad to hear it seriously glad to hear
it um
my understanding is that it was a charge
that was introduced and with no
pro rata um reductions uh what i will do
however is ask the portfolio holder um
just to clarify everything around that
and to provide you with an answer and to
copy uh
other members just so that there is
clarity for the future for that thank
you
thank you councillor kettle do you have
a question
no
councillor rock
uh thank you chairman um we started the
meeting with a minute silence for david
and i would say that
i'm quite old
as people have probably noticed
and in 1983 i had
a slight uh acquaintance with david and
mess because i campaigned against him
when he first stood for parliament and i
walked around the streets with the late
shirley williams
which rather gives my age away and uh
and
that's the crumpler myself were
discussing my mother-in-law who received
a gardening prize from david mess in
the short period i lived in essex so uh
i'm familiar with that but um the
question i would ask and um
as uh
as you will remember council pemberton i
i myself was assaulted shortly after i
was
re-elected
uh and had the unfortunate experience of
being called a tory
um
i've seen since then i i've received a
couple of other incidents uh where
members of the public have been overly
aggressive with me and um
therefore i imagine other
members of this chamber have had similar
experiences where there has been a
degradation in behavior
um so
the chief executive myself did have some
discussions about that about what could
be done for councillors i noticed that's
been absent from some of the discussion
about protecting members of parliament
i'm sure it's more dilute for us than it
is for uh members of parliament uh
some of us will remember that uh the mp
for chelmsford an attempt was made on
his life with his sword and sadly his
assistant was killed a number of years
ago so it's not new but i just wondered
if we could renew chief executive might
renew his inquiries with the police
about what we might do and what advice
we might receive uh
in those sort of situations thank you
chairman
thank you thank you councillor rock um i
thought
and um thank you for your question um
clearly the psychological scars of being
uh
being accused of being the tory still
live and weigh heavily upon you uh and
i'm sure that the chief executive will
will enable any services that you need
but at turning to the substantive point
in some respects this is not new and
i'll give you a personal example
circa 2002
i had a ward member who
lived within 100 yards of my home
unhappy about a number of different
things
threatened myself and my wife and she
used to work to work past his house
every day to the doctor's surgery
and the then chief executive paul
lancaster was hugely supportive
particularly to my wife and as i recall
i think there was an injunction taken
out and i have no doubt whatsoever that
the current chief executive will provide
any and all support that any member of
this council feels they need either in
relation to an individual or to help
support and facilitate any advice and
support that any member might need to
have about how they might manage their
own personal safety
i think that you're absolutely right
the focus is on mps and of course there
are far more of us as
counsellors and
we are
particularly as we you know we return to
some
postcovid sense of normality more likely
to be in
people's homes
you know to speak to residents and
perhaps our mp colleagues
who have the benefit of you know
specific surgery premises
it's a live issue it is um
it should not be a price we pay for
democracy
unfortunately i regret to say
that to some degree it is a price that
we pay for democracy that those of us
who put ourselves forward
and you know across this chamber and
chambers up and down the land
more and more find themselves
on the wrong end of some fairly
vitriolic and angry people
and some of those people
um
move beyond being keyboard warriors but
i cannot only say
that my experience with this council
some years ago was that you will be
supported and i am absolutely clear that
david
will do whatever he can in his power if
anybody has any
uncertainty or any concern and that will
help work that problem for you
and clearly if that involves the police
service i have no doubt that
david will will help facilitate that
you are right to to raise it as an issue
uh councillor rock
and um you know it is just to be hoped
that
these dreadful and infrequent events
will ideally never happen again but
remain that remarkably infrequent thing
but you all work hard and you are all in
the public
eye and sometimes
regrettably that
has negative impacts and clearly just
come forward if anybody
feels the need for any support and
you know
all of us regardless of party badge will
stand with you
thank you uh councillor adam
thank
there's a ongoing enforcement case in my
ward that um i've been having quite a
lot of issues with
um
now i've been speaking to the
enforcement officer on this quite a lot
and i appreciate the work that's gone
into it to date as uh stockton hall farm
as the particular case but um through
my dealings with the officer and the
complainant on site it does appear that
um something sorry um so i must
interrupt it
um
we can't we can't have questions about
enforcement based on individual
properties i'm afraid
i'll try to i can make it more broad
okay try and make it more broad please
um
there are
i have been made aware of enforcement
cases
where
um i'd say holes in procedure may be
apparent which are negatively impacting
businesses
um
the
examples that i might use
um seem to suggest that
in waiting for planning applications to
be
um forthcoming
um
businesses on the neighboring sites are
negatively affected and that there's a
potential delay um i'm not trying to be
contentious here but i'm i'm trying to
work out a practical way that we as a
council can address the concerns of the
the complainants
with them
due regard to the process they set out
for enforcement thank you
thank you councillor adam um what uh
what else what i suggest is that um if
if i could ask councillor parry
and you to
touch base so that you can
speak in general terms and if there are
any specific issues
those can be picked up if that flags
anything
more broadly then clearly uh councillor
parry will um
be able to share with other members but
i think that's probably your first route
is is councillor parry um to see how we
can address the concerns of your your
residence so i apologize for swerving
that one
thank you
councillor
can i just can i just say
please just on any enforcement issue
and that applies to everybody in this
chamber please please come to me
directly there are there is a set
procedure
for enforcement cases
um and
i have every confidence in the
enforcement team but speak to me
individually
thank you do we have any further
questions
no thank you so i can
stop my timer
and apologize for the for the speed can
i just ask if if anybody may have
interfered with their hearing aids
during the the intermission is
inadvertently put on the wrong setting
that sometimes has had
an impact on on the mics
the mics were working perfectly well
before
the break and they're not working so
well now i'll just give you maybe a
little bit further back when you're
speaking to the mics
for the next section i apologize i just
don't know what's happened to mike yeah
councillor fielding you raise your hand
yes but um
i
find that
using one's connection to your mobile
stuck into the side of the
stink does help to cut down and it
doesn't you don't need the loot which
probably is the feedback okay thank you
um so item 19 now we're moving to the
motions on notice
and just to clarify that motion one
universal credit cuts uh once proposed
and seconded will be referred to the
cabinet for consideration and reports
without debate so please may or call on
councillors bert's together and or
cocked pose and second the following no
notice of motion
counselor particular yes i would like to
propose the motion
on a universal credit cards
thank you
and councillorcock
yes thank you chairman uh yes i would
like to second this motion concerning
the universal credit cards
thank you
thank you so that will be referred to
cabinet for consideration thank you
councillors
um
motion two we've got the climate change
summit cop26
so this motion once proposed and
seconded will be uh debated at the
meeting and please may i call on
uh councillors juned and jenny
councillor jenny frashley to propose in
second the following notice of motion
uh thank you um this the wording of this
social notice of motion was very very
carefully considered um one of the
things that i took on board was the
local government association's uh
position um if you go onto their website
um that that you can see that they have
specifically and cross party and with a
conservative lead have asked for formal
representation of local government with
a dedicated chapter for sub-national
governments in the official agreement
reached at cop 26 to recognize the
importance of sub-national actors in
co-designing and delivering climate
action and ensuring local government is
politically and financially empowered to
meet that ambition and those are the
wordings from the local government
association website they also asked for
a dedicated local government today which
i believe has now been granted
so my my um
my
motion was to make sure that we all
right across local government had a
universal uh
display of unity on asking government to
support local government
it is not only the national audit office
that has mentioned about the problems
with um meeting local government and
meeting net zero and the critical role
that they have to play and the services
they provide and the clarification that
is needed on the role of government on
local authorities in that task of
reaching net zero
there was also a a report um a article
rather by lord zeban in the local
government chronicle just this last week
and lord devon if you remember was a
conservative
i believe environment minister now chief
head of the climate change committee
and he has also highlighted the crucial
role of local authorities and actually
has said that they are crucial partners
in enabling change
and that about a third of all uk
emissions are dependent on sectors
shaped or influenced by local government
practice policy or and partnerships
he said that local government has a key
influencing role
uh and a community role
but he also emphasized not only in that
article but in the climate change
committee's local authorities and sixth
carbon budget
that local government are a cornerstone
of the range of partnerships close to
local people and know what works best in
their area
here but in in that article in that
report that he headed up he also stated
that the range of powers available to
local authorities are not sufficient
due to gaps in key powers that prevent
systems
scale or holistic approaches policy and
funding barriers and a lack of capacity
and skills caused by funding cuts and
that was lord deben and the climate
change committee that i am quoting there
so many of the urgent changes and
decisions needed to reduce emissions and
reach net zero have a strong local
dimension a one-size-fits-all
approach will not work and we do need to
make sure that that local authorities
are properly represented and empowered
this council as all councils however has
a position as a place shaper a convener
of communities and businesses purchasers
problem solvers able to meet the
challenge if we are given the policies
finance and clarity by government
and my notice of motion is to make sure
that a key message goes through that is
supported by all those that all those
bodies the local government association
the climate change committee committee
people like lord debon people like adept
which are the association of
directors environment planning and
transport who've also worked with the
local government association and said
exactly the same as well as the national
audit office uh response they have all
asked for a key role for local
government in the task of
reaching net zero they've all said
without
any change between them they've all said
that government needs to enable the
right resources and skills and that they
just need to be
a development of the relationship
between local authorities and government
on the overall expectations on roles and
responsibility that there needs to be
good communication
and it was also noted in all of those by
the adept by
local government association by the
climate change committee and by the lga
that funding is critical for work for
local authority work on net zero
one of those organized one of those
reports did say that the bidding process
for grants and the diffuse
accountabilities across government
departments are not helping
so
we wanted to make i wanted to make sure
that i was reflecting the local
authority's role and the local
government's role and the local
government's agreement right across the
country to make sure that that we all
are working towards the same thing
making sure that local government has
the power and the ability to address net
zero in our areas
and that dedicated chapter for local
government was a specific local
government
association request
backed by the leader of the local
government association and all parties
on the local government association
without any anybody um
removing
not voting for that change so that is
something that i think we need to we
need reassurance and making sure that
the enabling role the community role the
empowering role of local government is
recognized and this is a plea to make
sure that we have an unanimous view
going forward to a lakshana from all
councils across the country that we are
up to the game and are able to be to
address climate change if we are given
their resources and unable to do so so i
do hope that this is not taken in any
way to be party political this is taken
as a clear
act shout out for the role and the
support and the strength of local
government in this country
thank you councillor junior councillor
jenny freshly would you like to propose
uh sorry second and speak i'd like to
second and reserve my right to speak
thank you
any um
councillors like to speak on this
listen uh councillor dixon
thank you chairman
climate change will be delivered uh via
the local authorities without a shadow
of a doubt
um
i've got a
couple of minor amendments um
essentially to uh pull it points five
and six obviously as far as the notice
of motion is concerned points one to
four are merely for noting
and certainly there can be no
disagreement with that in as much as
we're very happy to support and note
those
uh councillor junior referred to uh the
the chapter which is point number seven
uh obviously it's a situation whereby i
understand the local government
association and that decision is if you
like is already there so whether that is
required uh i will leave up to up to
members uh but essentially i do have an
amendment in respect to five and six i
shall read those out and then i'll
actually just speak to them if i may
the
wording is being passed around
number five
the amendments be
the i'll read it in full to ensure that
this council can continue to undertake
the critical work needed
local authorities need reassurance from
government so that they can confidently
prepare budgets adequately ensure a
robust planning framework and support
effective technical technological
investment and industry standards to
allow local government to make urgent
progress to meet its challenges in the
years ahead
we are doing it we want to continue
doing it
item six we urge that this council
writes to the government and
specifically to alex sharma the
president of cop 26
to acknowledge the environmental
progressive record-breaking and the
greenest ever uk government and to urge
that national government continues to
work effectively with local government
on addressing climate change
those are the amendments that are
proposed and i believe they've been
circulated if i now quite simply refer
to a few issues obviously um council of
june had made points of the fact that uh
uh climate change initiatives will be
delivered through local authorities
and obviously the united kingdom does
have a plan to reduce and slash
greenhouse emissions by 78
in 2035.
some of the bullet points of that plan
are you know offshore wind
producing enough offshore wind to power
every home quadrupling as much
how much and to produce 40 gigawatts by
2030
hydrogen
working with industry
aiming to generate five gigawatts of low
carbon hydrogen production aiming to
develop the first town heated entirely
by hydrogen
electric vehicles and i know there are a
number of electric vehicle drivers
within our midst
backing our world leading car
manufacturing bases included in the west
midlands our own patch you know
basically and accelerating the
transition to electrical vehicles and
electric transport
public transport
cycling walking
items close to everybody's hearts i
think making cycling and walking more
attractive ways to travel
and investing in zero emission public
transport
i'm not sure if i see them around
stratford but certainly i do see plenty
of electric buses in soviet hall
homes and public buildings making our
homes schools and hospitals greener
warmer and more efficient yes we need to
actually improve the efficiency and the
energy efficiency of all of our homes if
we can get them all up to standards b
and c brilliant so much better and that
work will be delivered through local
authorities
nature protecting and restoring our
natural environment something i think
close to the chairman's heart planting
30 000 hectares of trees every year i'll
be with the chairman on the 5th of
november planting trees so essentially
there is a plan government is delivering
it it is being delivered through local
authorities and i propose the two
amendments chairman as i have read out
thank you thank you councillor dixon i'm
now looking for a second uh for the
amendment we've got councillor fielding
please
i would like to to second
uh councillor dixon's
comments i've been working with um
the trials trust to see about improving
improving footpaths right away
uh sorry counselor needs pastor phil
quickly please
um chairman i think you've had a second
but
i think you've had a second but the next
question is about whether
susan junit would castle tuna would
accept that as a friendly amendment or
not
okay
i i i note with interest that um the
third amendment has now disappeared
which we you mentioned to me before
which was that you were going to vote
against the local chapter until i
pointed out to you of course that the
conservatives at the local government
association had specifically asked for
that local chapter so i i i do accept
that uh you have amended it slightly
however uh when you look at the national
audit office it does not point to the
fact that this is the most
environmentally progressive
record-breaking and greenest ever uk
government that was not what i was
asking about i was asking for a united
front from this council to the
government to make sure that all local
government was probably recognized and
made that to make sure that we as local
government got there the an enablement
and the powers and the resources to do
the work properly and i wanted that to
be a party political cross-party uh
representation uh i'm not sure what what
my group will take of this is it
possible to have my a five-minute break
just to discuss that
yeah i'd be happy to allow a five-minute
break so meeting uh john and two five
two
oh one of the other ones which comes
got the other one
my feedback in there
thank you everyone so let's resume the
meeting but before we continue with the
motion we're coming up to
uh closer play so please not suggest a
vote to extend the meeting by um an hour
is there anyone can have someone propose
this for me please counselor dixon and a
seconder council junaid thank you so the
meeting can continue
that's fine you please leave if you need
to at the set time
yeah please my i uh hand over to uh
sorry phil grafton
so just just to clarify where we are
um
if we could deal with this in three
parts
um first of all um
points one to four of the motion are all
points just for noting
so it might be that
it might be that you will be all in
agreement to accept one to four
on five to six at the moment
um
there is a rejection of it as a friendly
amendment but i
i suspect there might be
an amendment to the amendment
and then lastly in tragedy we can deal
with point seven lastly
so so
do you want to look at one to four first
and maybe seek agreement to that so we
can clear that off
thank you so we have um the original
proposer and second uh
yeah thank you that they're onto the
screen for uh the motion so oral
council's in agreement for
point so one to four the motion
thank you that's agreed
um and now uh we'll go to point five
five and six check generally if i can
just
the the audio is going out live and then
we are working on that on the visual so
that the screen will will move very
quickly yeah council dixon
but certainly i uh i would hope that uh
our wording of five could be a friendly
acceptance uh on behalf of uh the
proposals of the uh original uh
motion and
a change of
wording
if i may
liaise with mine
removing some of perhaps the
political nature
of item six
we now read we urge that this council
writes to the government
specifically to alex sharma the
president of cop26
to acknowledge the work already being
done
and to urge that the national government
continues to work effectively with local
government on addressing climate change
thank you
councillor
in the interest of making sure that this
is carried forwards that we have a
strong message
to government and to alex sharma and
could cop 26 from this council as well
as from so many other councils across
the country i am prepared to accept this
as a friendly amendment and thank you
for uh being so considerate to be able
to take this forward uh i would like to
be able to say to alex sharma this
council
is doing good work but wants to do more
and how can you enable us
thank you council judy and could we just
seek from the second to the council
jenny frantically her acceptance of that
friendly amendment
i i will accept that friendly amendment
yes
uh thank you councillor fielding would
you like to speak
only in
um
backing up what's been said with regards
to the amendment and seconding it
okay thank you so we are in agreement
for the amendment and the amendment of
the amendment is that agreed by
councillors for points five and six
thank you
so that just leaves point seven so we've
got a motion on the table from
councillor juned
seconded by councillor jenny fragili
and the question is
for
open for debate
thank you um councillor juned please
they quit the chapter
0.7 uh asking for a dedicated chapter is
exactly what the local government
association is asking for i would urge
you to to
support your own local government
association in it their talks with alex
sharma
thank you uh councillor cargill
chair thank you
gosh it's all breaking out during wwe
isn't it may i make a suggestion
why not a named vote then we can present
that to
the secretary of state
as um something this whole council
agrees with do i have a supporter with
them
councillor cargill please can you just
clarify
that please
ah i just realized you've split it into
three haven't you
so we can't do that can we
it might take a while
yeah
no okay i withdraw that but
the idea was good
okay we'll get we're getting the uh
council of shenzhen
with regards to uh item seven um
of this motion
when you
talk about a dedicated chapter
one thing i will say is that obviously
the lga are present
as you know
day 11
is local government day
the lga will be making
the case for all local councils on day
11 which is the last full day
of the uh of cop 26.
um
i'm guessing that we've got faith in the
lga and we should leave that with them
to pursue
and i'm not quite sure
if you like if you're looking at seven
what it is you would want
to happen with a wizard seven so maybe
just a little bit more clarification
i just want to be able to say to the to
to put um power to the lga when they're
speaking to alex sharma because at the
moment
as i understand it the local government
day has been agreed by alex sharma the
dedicated chapter in the official
agreement has not yet been agreed
and i'm asking that um that we back the
local government association's call for
that local dedicated chapter
a counselor
yep so i i understand what you're saying
there um
that we we give support are you saying
we send a letter to the lga or to alex
sharma
perhaps it might be best to do it to
both
thank you
sorry please bear with me just
new to all this
so so whenever at the point where where
the
seven has been explained we've still got
five and six to vote on and seven as
well if you want to take them
collectively you could do
um that might be the better approach um
so it might be that unless there are
speakers here you want to go to the
further speakers you might want to go
straight to the boat
okay so we will now uh take a sorry uh
council jenny fragi would you like to
speak
just returned to cargill's idea if we're
just taking the single vote could it
then be a named vote because then every
person here would be putting their
backing to this
very important uh motion
chairman yeah you can have a name vote
that would be that would be on the basis
of voting on five six and seven yeah
thank you uh councillor [ __ ] i will
second that thank you chad
i'll go ahead then please
don't give me the lip in the eyes go
ahead um
okay
all right uh counselor pursuer
yes sorry um could we read out again uh
the amendments as in their final draft
please thank you
sure
sure i can read out 0.5 um
to ensure that this council can continue
to undertake the critical work needed
local authorities need reassurance from
government so that they can confidently
prepare
yeah confidently prepare budgets
adequately ensure a robust planning
framework and support effective tech
technological investment and industrial
standards to allow local government to
make urgent pro progress to meet its
challenges in the years ahead and
council dixon or councillor
please may you do the 0.6
um
so number six now reads we urge the
discounts council rights to the
government and specifically to alex
sharma the president of cop26 to
acknowledge work already done
and to urge the national government must
continue to work effectively with local
government on addressing climate change
i think i've added a word must in there
but it actually reads and to urge
national government to work more to work
effectively with local governments
okay yeah let's um vote on the amendment
uh five and six and also the original uh
point seven excuse me i'm talking at the
moment i will i will now invite you to
speak your council jennifer actually my
apologies chair um have we dropped them
more effectively
yes
have you dropped accounts
yeah but the version i showed you
the council unit does say the government
continues to work effectively with local
government that was a word
okay so i will now call on uh david
buckland to take a named vote on this
please
okay
so as long as we're clear we're voting
now on the amended two um points on five
and six and whether you accept point
seven as well so we're taking the three
in totality
if i call out your name could you please
respond saying whether you are or
against or abstaining in relation to
chairman councillor fitter council
officer for
thank you uh vice chairman councillor
dixon councillor dixon four
thank you councillor adam councillor
adam four thank you councillor alcock
councilcock four thank you council
barca
councillor barker iv thank you
councillor cargill council cargill 4
thank you councillor crump that's the
crop for
thank you councillor curtis councillor
curtis for thank you councillor fielding
councillor fielding four
thank you councillor fleming
councillor fleming for
thank you councillor boytick
councillor foytek4 thank you councillor
foreman
thank you councillor ian fragili
thank you council jenny frenchly
thank you uh councillor harvey
thank you councillor junaid councillor
junaid iv thank you councillor kettle
councillor kettle for
thank you councillor mills council mills
for thank you um councillor parry
councillor parry four
thank you and councilman pemberton
that's the pemberton four
thank you uh councillor patekela
councillor tagalog four thank you
councillor richards
thank you um councillor
briley
anton riley four
thank you councillor rock
councillor rock four thank you um
councillor rolfe councilwolf four
thank you councillor shenton council
thank you and councillor wally hoggins
thank you chairman there were 27 votes
for and none against those countries
unanimously thank you council thank you
for your patience uh during that one so
now moving on to item 20 which is urgent
business so there's only one thing that
i've been asked to mention which is on a
the 13th of december uh please be
available for the whole afternoon
because i think it's going to be a
relatively busy
afternoon there uh so more information
about that we'll follow um otherwise i
can
council barca sorry
sorry um can you tell me what time
that's planned to be is it all afternoon
so it will be a normal council at two
o'clock and then it's looking like um we
will reconvene at six o'clock as well uh
but more information about that will
come out uh in the next few days and
weeks um but other from that i can now
declare this meeting closed and thank
you everyone for for being here today
you